deux ans après son lancement en pleine
pandémie le panier bleu devient
transactionnel avec nous ce soir alain
dumas le directeur général du panier
bleus bonsoir monsieur dumas
pourquoi il a fallu deux ans et même un
peu plus finalement pour que le panier
bleus deviennent en fait transactionnel
mais en fait il faut se remettre d'un
gérant perspectives un peu le banc des
bleus a été lancée au début de la
pandémie il y avait aucune intention de
vaincre transactionnel l'idée c'était de
promouvoir le fait de l'achat local fait
que c'était vraiment un organisme a été
créé pour la chaux dakar en cours d'euro
on a fait des chantiers qui se sont
attelés les chantiers pour l'avenir du
commerce de détail et c'est à ce moment
là qu'on a je dirais réalisées hors de
tout d'eux qu'ils avaient un besoin pour
créer non seulement un site
transactionnel met vraiment je dirais
une destination pour mettre en relation
les commerçants québécois et les
consommateurs pour qu'ils lâchent la
qualité il eut un sondage netendances au
mois de mars qui disait que seulement 14
% des québécois réutiliser le panier
bleus est-ce que c'est pas un peu
décevant
en fait
c'est un peu juste et vrai que c'est un
peu drôle d'antan que seulement 14 %
parce que probablement que 80% des sites
internet au québec n'ont pas la chance
d'avoir accès à 14 % des consommateurs
et ce qui est surtout plus important de
noter c'est que la valeur du panier
bleus étaient pas nécessairement de
créer du trafic sur le site web c'était
vraiment de faire la promotion c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs les investissements
ont très peu été fait en technologie ont
été faites beaucoup plus en marketing je
dirais en campagne de sensibilisation
pour l'achat dakar mais 14% donc s'avoue
satisfait parce qu'elle va quand même
beaucoup d'argent public ça y est eu
énormément de promotion on en a parlé
autant comme au temps du panier bleus
oui bon on fait solide 14% ça représente
je voudrais grosso modo nous nécessite
qu'on a ce qu'on environ un million de
visiteurs uniques l'année dernière ça
vous donne à peu près l'amplitude du
nombre de visiteurs pour nous ça veut
dire un million de contacts avec des
commerces avec des consommateurs et la
chance de les sensibiliser ou au
commerce local lorsqu'il faut dire c'est
que on a une banque de données d'un folk
avec plus de cent mille consommateurs
s'étant dits juge pas je défends de
lanciers panier bleus ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que l'ancien d'année
bleus avait vraiment une mission de
sensibilisation l'achat local tandis que
l'on a vraiment quelque chose de
différent 4 millions ont été injectés
par le gouvernement du québec jusqu'à
maintenant il ya encore 12 millions par
le biais d'investissement québec le
panier bleus se transforme échange d'
entité mais je repose la question
jusqu'à quel point ça vaut la peine de
mettre des millions de dollars en argent
public dans une aventure face à amazon
amazon qui va qui va quand même jeu
quand même chercher en ce moment la
moitié des achats sur internet au québec
wima mais en fait c'est une raison
supplémentaire d'investir dans ce sens
au québec on a longtemps essayé de les
cheveux je fais du commerce électronique
de plus le vin depuis plus de 25 ans on
note souvent fait des
initiatives au québec malheureusement
nous faut les gérer on n'a pas assez
d'ambition on n'a pas là autant au
niveau investissement pour réaliser
certaines ambitions ceci étant dit vous
savez très bien la machine amazon c'est
plusieurs centaines de millions de
dollars donc déjà le 22 millions en
question c'est quand même limité et de
l'autre côté on le sait il ya environ
25% de la population au québec qui
vraiment sensibiliser gérer de façon
intense à l'achat local qui sont prêts à
faire des efforts à 100 cela est le plus
gros problème c'est que les places de
marché international ne donne pas de
visibilité à ces gens là avec nous on
veut créer une destination pour ce
public donc les les commerçants
québécois les entreprises québécoises
peuvent s'inscrire sur le nouveau site
les entreprises étrangères qui ont des
franchisés ici locaux peuvent le faire
également si je me trompe pas
en fait tout dépend dans ce qu'on a mis
comme nan parce qu'on voulait pour on
voulait je dirais punir les gens qui ont
décidé d'avoir une une enseigne
étrangère si une enseigne et appartient
à plus de 75% à des propriétaires
québécois à ce moment là et on doit
s'inscrire est ce que ça coûte quelque
chose pour s'inscrire
à ce moment si cette côte absolument
rien ces bases est vraiment sur le
modèle d'affaires je désirais d'une une
place de marché donc les frais sont
reliés à la transaction c'est vraiment
une durée d'une commission sur la
transaction et cette commission là
comporte en fait des services c'est à
dire que en tant que vrai place de
marché on va s'occuper du service à la
clientèle on va absorber les de frais de
cartes de crédit et elle est conviée la
commission
ça dépend toujours des catégories vous
savez comme moi j'ai travaillé longtemps
l'alimentation l'alimentation des marges
de profits très très minime voilà donc
les les les commissions sont chargées
selon les catégories était le plus
faible la commission que chez amazon
je voudrais c'est assez comparable parce
que toutes les places de marchés ont à
peu près d échelle comparable ce que je
vous disais reste c'est je vous donnerai
le défi si vous voulez d'aller voir
amazon son système de deux prix de
rémunération c'est très très très
compliqué nous on s'est donné le défi
d'être transparent donc c'est très
facile pour un commerçant le savoir
c'est quoi le courir est vraiment une
dernière question monsieur dumas c'est
quoi votre objectif là concrètement vous
voulez gagner combien parts de marché
sur amazon au québec en fait
premièrement on ne veut pas se mettre en
position d'être en compétition avec
maison on se reverra comme une
alternative à la zone lorsqu'on dit tout
simplement c'est quelqu'un pour qui
l'achat responsable la charge vous irez
local est important ce qu'on leur dit
c'est sur le peigne et bleu peu importe
la transaction vous faites ça va avoir
un impact positif sur l'économie du
québec avec toutes les ventes qui vont
se rassurent le peigné bleus sont des
vents pour nous aucune valeur
supplémentaire sur l'économie pour la
suite d'écoutés on va regarder les
résultats bien entendu l'intérêt des
gens et l'intérêt des commerçants à
travailler dans ce modèle bonne chance
monsieur dumas merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit